(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nessa primeira aula do módulo 4, nós vamos
falar sobre o ITBI, que é o Imposto
de Transmissão de Bens Imóveis.
Algumas prefeituras usam como sinônimos ITIV ou ISTI.
É tudo a mesma coisa, é tudo sinônimo
de ITBI.
O ITBI, então, ele acontece quando existe transmissão
de bens imóveis entre pessoas vivas.
Por quê?
Porque se fosse uma transferência de bem imóvel
decorrente do patrimônio de uma pessoa morta, seria
recolhido o ITCMD, que é o Imposto de
Transmissão Causa Mortes ou Doação, que é quando
ocorre transferência de um bem imóvel de uma
pessoa que faleceu ou se for proveniente de
uma doação.
Então, no caso de uma arrematação, o imposto
que deve ser pago é o ITBI.
O ITBI, ele é um imposto municipal e
ele tem uma alíquota variável.
Essa alíquota vai variar de município para município.
O mais comum é que essa alíquota fique
entre 2% e 3% do valor
da venda do imóvel, mas existem alguns municípios
que chegam a colocar essa alíquota em 5
% do valor da transação.
Aqui você deve pesquisar qual é a alíquota
aplicada pelo município onde fica localizado o imóvel
de seu interesse.
Volte a fazer aquela ressalva de que existem
mais de 5 mil municípios no país e
seria quase impossível compilar todas essas informações.
A título de exemplo, aqui nas cidades de
São Paulo, a alíquota do ITBI é de
3% sobre o valor da negociação do
imóvel.
A legislação municipal, ela vai dispor qual é
o prazo de recolhimento do ITBI.
E se você não recolher dentro desse prazo
de recolhimento, a legislação municipal, ela também vai
colocar a previsão de que você pague uma
multa.
Então, novamente, você deve realizar a pesquisa de
qual o prazo de recolhimento do ITBI no
município onde fica localizado o imóvel de seu
interesse.
Então, você vai pesquisar a alíquota e o
prazo de recolhimento.
É importante que você respeite o prazo para
que você não sofra a incidência de multa,
para que você não tem que pagar uma
multa por ter recolhido o imposto fora do
prazo.
O ITBI, ele é calculado com base no
valor venal do imóvel ou no valor da
transação do imóvel, o que for maior.
O que é valor venal?
O valor venal é uma estimativa do valor
do imóvel realizada pelo poder público, ou seja,
no caso do ITBI, como ela é imposto
municipal, as prefeituras, elas vão estimar qual é
o valor de cada imóvel que fica localizado
dentro daquele município.
Esse é o chamado valor venal.
Então, quando ocorre uma transação, a prefeitura, ela
tem o registro desse valor venal.
Vai ser aplicado o valor venal ou o
valor da transação, o que for maior.
Então, se o valor da transação for menor
do que o valor venal, vai ser aplicado
o valor venal.
Se o valor da transação for maior do
que o valor venal, vai ser aplicado o
valor da transação, para que incida a alíquota
do ITBI.
Como grande parte das prefeituras tem esse sistema
informatizado, é possível que você simule o recolhimento
do ITBI no imóvel de seu interesse.
Então, você pode simular no site da prefeitura
qual seria o valor venal do imóvel específico
de seu interesse e verificar se esse valor
venal seria maior ou menor do que o
valor de transação, sobre qual valor seria aplicada
a alíquota do ITBI.
Como funciona o cálculo do ITBI nos leilões
de imóvel?
No leilão judicial, o ITBI deve ser calculado
com base no valor da arrematação, não importando
o valor venal arbitrado pela prefeitura.
Então, não importa qual é o valor venal,
importa o valor da arrematação.
Não importa, então, se o valor da arrematação
é superior ou inferior ao valor venal.
De qualquer forma, vai ser afastado o valor
venal e o recolhimento vai ser sobre o
valor da arrematação.
Isso é jurisprudência do STJ, que é o
Superior Tribunal de Justiça.
Eu separei aqui o trecho da jurisprudência que
fala sobre isso.
A turma conheceu parcialmente do recurso e, nessa
parte, deu-lhe provimento por entender que a
base de cálculo do ITBI em arrematação judicial
é o valor alcançado na asta pública.
Asta pública é sinônimo de leilão público, tendo
em vista que a arrematação representa a aquisição
do bem alienado judicialmente.
Deve-se considerar como valor venal do imóvel
aquele atingido em asta pública, que pode ser
inferior ao valor da avaliação.
Então, afasta o valor venal e aplica o
valor da arrematação.
Coloquei ainda mais um julgado que fala a
mesma coisa, que é para mostrar como esse
entendimento é consolidado pelo STJ.
Asta pública, valor da arrematação e não o
valor da avaliação judicial.
Já se decidiu, no âmbito dessa corte, que
o cálculo daquele imposto, ou seja, o ITBI,
há de ser feito com base no valor
alcançado pelos bens da arrematação e não pelo
valor da avaliação judicial.
Então, afasta o valor da avaliação judicial, afasta
o valor venal e aplica o valor da
arrematação.
Sobre o valor da arrematação, deve incidir a
alíquota do ITBI e aí vai depender da
alíquota adotada em cada município.
Se é 2, 3, em algumas raras exceções,
5%.
O mesmo entendimento também se aplica para os
leilões extrajudiciais.
Coloquei aqui mais um julgado e é um
julgado também do STJ.
O que importa pra gente aqui é o
que está sublinhado.
Então, vamos lá, no item 2.
O entendimento aplicado pela Corte Paulista está de
acordo com o STJ, o qual afirma que,
nas hipóteses de alienação judicial do imóvel, seu
valor venal corresponde àquele pelo qual foi arrematado
em esta pública, inclusive para fins do cálculo
do ITBI.
Ademais, em virtude da similaridade do leilão extrajudicial
com a arrematação judicial, aplica-se o entendimento
pacífico na primeira sessão do STJ de que
aquele corresponde à esta.
Ou seja, que o valor que deve ser
usado como base para recolhimento do TBI também
no leilão extrajudicial é o valor da arrematação
em leilão extrajudicial e não o valor venal
ou o valor da avaliação.
Vou afastar esses dois valores e vai ser
aplicado o valor da arrematação.
Como pedir o cálculo pelo valor da arrematação?
As prefeituras e seus sites, elas realizam o
cálculo direto pelo valor venal, porque como eu
falei, as prefeituras têm estimado o valor venal
de todos os imóveis que ficam localizados naquele
município.
Então, quando você vai emitir o ITBI diretamente
no site da prefeitura, é normal que a
prefeitura já coloque automaticamente o valor venal.
E aí você vai ter que pedir uma
reestimativa daquele cálculo, vai ter que pedir para
a prefeitura que ela faça o cálculo de
acordo com o valor da arrematação.
Então, você deve fazer um requerimento na prefeitura
para que seja aplicado o valor da arrematação.
Existem duas hipóteses para esse requerimento.
Existem prefeituras que realizam esse requerimento de forma
muito rápida.
O arrematante vai apresentar na prefeitura o valor
que ele pagou na arrematação daquele imóvel e
a prefeitura, de imediato, já emite guia para
o pagamento do ITBI, levando em base o
valor da arrematação.
E existem prefeituras em que você faz esse
requerimento e esse requerimento demora de três a
quatro meses para ser analisado e aí depois
realmente a prefeitura vai reconhecer que o valor
do ITBI deve ser pago de acordo com
o valor da arrematação.
Para que você não espere esse prazo, se
for o caso da prefeitura de seu interesse,
você pode recolher o imposto a mais e
depois pedir a restituição que a prefeitura ela
realiza essa restituição desse imposto.
A título de exemplo, aqui na cidade de
São Paulo, acontece essa segunda hipótese.
A prefeitura leva em média três a quatro
meses para realizar a análise desse requerimento que
o arrematante faz.
Então, às vezes, é mais vantajoso que você
recolha para que você possa, de imediato, já
registrar o imóvel em seu nome, porque o
pagamento do ITBI é um dos requisitos que
o cartório analisa para registrar o imóvel no
nome do arrematante.
Então, você não consegue fazer esse registro sem
pagamento do ITBI.
Então, no caso aqui de São Paulo, como
demora muito, você pode realizar o pagamento e
depois pedir a restituição.
E aí, com esse pagamento que você fez,
você vai lá, registra o imóvel, às vezes
você já até vendeu o imóvel, enquanto a
prefeitura ainda está analisando aquele seu requerimento.
E também, recolher o imposto e depois pedir
a restituição afasta a aplicação de multa, porque
você recolheu no prazo certo e depois está
pedindo a restituição.
Não há que se falar em multa nesse
caso, porque você recolheu no prazo correto.
Existe outra possibilidade de você realizar esse requerimento,
que é através de um processo judicial.
O processo que acontece mais rápido para esse
caso seria um mandado de segurança.
Então, você pode entrar com o mandado de
segurança que o judiciário, ele vai analisar aquele
seu processo quase que de imediato, porque o
mandado de segurança tem tramitação prioritária expressamente prevista
em lei.
Então, a lei diz que o mandado de
segurança, ele tem que correr de forma muito
rápida.
Para você requerer através de um mandado de
segurança, você vai precisar de um advogado.
Eu vou deixar aqui nessa aula um modelo
de mandado de segurança que você pode usar
só para encher os seus dados, mais uma
vez com aquele objetivo de que você possa
economizar com advogado, porque o advogado ele vai
ter menos trabalho.
Afinal de contas, a peça já vai estar
pronta, ele só vai precisar revisar aquela peça,
não vai ter trabalho de ficar horas e
horas escrevendo aquela peça.
Basta que você preencha aqui no modelo que
eu vou disponibilizar os seus dados e você
leve para um advogado.
Se você recorrer ao poder judiciário, você não
precisa fazer o pagamento prévio para depois pedir
a restituição.
Você vai fazer o pagamento que o judiciário
mandar que você faça, com o ITBI sendo
calculado pelo valor da arrematação.
O próprio poder judiciário, ele afasta a multa
pelo atraso.
Então, você vai recolher sobre o valor da
arrematação e sem multa, caso você opte por
recolher ao poder judiciário.
E aqui entra uma questão, o leilão judicial,
ele é unânime, as prefeituras já aplicam, mas
você vai ter que fazer um requerimento à
prefeitura.
Você pode fazer esse requerimento à prefeitura ou
recorrer ao poder judiciário.
No poder judiciário, esse requerimento vai ser analisado
de forma mais rápida do que na prefeitura,
na maioria dos casos.
Se for um exemplo aqui de São Paulo,
com certeza vai ser mais rápido.
O judiciário aqui de São Paulo, ele analisa
a humanidade de segurança de forma muito rápida,
enquanto a prefeitura leva de três a quatro
meses para fazer esse requerimento, para analisar esse
requerimento administrativo.
Se você se deparar com uma prefeitura que
faça isso de pronto, que você leve o
valor da arrematação e ela já emita ali
imediatamente a guia para o ITBI de acordo
com o valor da arrematação em leilão judicial,
tudo bem, você não precisa recorrer ao poder
judiciário.
Agora, saiba que para o leilão extrajudicial, as
prefeituras, elas não aplicam esse entendimento de forma
simples.
Elas só aplicam esse entendimento quando o poder
judiciário determina que elas apliquem que o valor
do ITBI vai ser calculado com base no
valor da arrematação.
Então, para o leilão extrajudicial, é quase que
uma regra você recorrer ao poder judiciário para
que você tenha como base de cálculo para
o pagamento do ITBI o valor da arrematação
e não o valor venal.
Então, para o leilão judicial, você vai ter
que recorrer ao poder judiciário.
E aqui cabe uma observação, quando você for
recorrer ao poder judiciário para um leilão extrajudicial,
você vai ter custos, você vai ter que
pagar um advogado para que ele faça aquilo.
Então, analise se realmente vale a pena você
recorrer ou não, porque pode ser que o
valor da arrematação seja muito próximo ao valor
venal, que essa diferença pequena não faça com
que valha a pena você recorrer ao poder
judiciário.
Então, analise no seu caso, faça a busca
do valor venal no site da Prefeitura daquele
imóvel, veja se o valor venal realmente está
muito distante do valor da arrematação.
Se ele estiver próximo, avalie se realmente você
quer recorrer ao poder judiciário, porque você vai
ter gastos com advogado para que você faça
isso.
Atenção para arrematações feitas em São Paulo e
só em São Paulo isso aqui que eu
vou falar.
O Tribunal de Justiça de São Paulo fixou
tese jurídica de que a base de cálculo
do ITBI deve ser calculada sobre o valor
do negócio jurídico realizado e ser adquirido em
asta pública sobre o valor da arrematação ou
sobre o valor venal do imóvel para fins
de IPTU, aquele que for maior afastando o
valor venal de referência.
O que o Tribunal de Justiça de São
Paulo entende?
Que o valor venal vai ser descaracterizado, vai
ser aplicado o valor da arrematação.
Mas se o valor para a base de
cálculo do IPTU for maior do que o
valor da arrematação, aí vai ser aplicado o
valor da base de cálculo do IPTU.
Então, basicamente, existem três valores.
O valor da arrematação, o valor venal para
fins de IPTU e o valor venal para
fins de ITBI.
São valores diferentes.
Apesar de ser calculado pela mesma prefeitura, a
prefeitura coloca valores diferentes.
Então, a tendência é que o valor venal
para fins de IPTU seja menor do que
o valor venal para fins de ITBI.
E no caso do Judiciário Paulista vai ser
entre o valor da arrematação ou o valor
venal para fins de IPTU o que for
maior, descaracterizando de qualquer forma o valor venal
do ITBI.
O valor venal que a prefeitura aplica para
o ITBI não vai ser usado em qualquer
forma em arrematação judicial.
Vai ser usado o valor da arrematação ou
o valor venal para fins de IPTU.
Vou dar um exemplo prático de um imóvel
que eu arrematei aqui na cidade de São
Paulo.
O imóvel foi arrematado por um pouco mais
de 430 mil reais.
O valor venal para fins de ITBI era
de mais de um milhão de reais.
Se não me engano, era um milhão e
cinco mil reais, alguma coisa assim.
E o valor da arrematação foi por 430
mil.
Ou seja, o valor venal para fins de
ITBI era muito superior ao valor da arrematação.
Então, eu recorri ao Judiciário através de uma
área de segurança e aí o Judiciário mandou
que fosse aplicado o valor da arrematação ou
o valor venal para fins de IPTU, o
que fosse maior.
O que aconteceu nesse meu caso?
O valor da arrematação, 430 mil.
O valor venal para fins de IPTU, um
pouco mais de 600 mil.
E aí foi afastado aquele valor venal para
fins de ITBI, que era de um milhão,
joga fora, não vai ser usado para nada.
E aí ficou entre o valor da arrematação,
430, e o valor venal para fins de
IPTU, um pouco mais de 600 mil reais.
Como o Tribunal de Justiça de São Paulo
tem esse entendimento, foi aplicado nesse caso o
valor venal para fins de IPTU.
Ainda assim, era uma diferença gritante do que
se fosse utilizado o valor venal para fins
de ITBI, que era de mais de um
milhão.
Nesse caso, se fosse utilizado como base de
cálculo o valor venal para fins de ITBI,
pagaria um pouco mais de 30 mil reais
de ITBI para transferência do bem.
Como foi afastado esse valor e na prática
foi pago sobre o valor venal para fins
de IPTU, o imposto saiu por um pouco
mais de 18 mil reais.
Então, uma diferença de quase 12 mil reais.
Isso aí era muito expressivo, isso aí você
não pode deixar passar.
Faça a análise do seu caso e veja
se realmente o valor da arrematação está muito
longe do valor venal para fins de ITBI.
E se for no caso aqui do Judiciário
de São Paulo, verifique ainda qual é o
valor venal para fins de IPTU, que nesse
caso, no Judiciário aqui de São Paulo, vai
ser aplicado o valor da arrematação ou o
valor venal para fins de IPTU, o que
foi maior.
Para o resto do Brasil é aplicado o
entendimento do STJ, que é o valor da
arrematação.
Fique atento a isso, que isso pode te
economizar bastante dinheiro e aumentar ainda mais o
seu lucro em um leilão de imóvel.